[Music]
welcome to day two of Netflix geek week
2022. today is film day I'm Jada Martell
I was recently in the movie meadowlords
and you may have also seen me in knives
out in it I've seen you in boat and I'm
Reese I'm that one guy who makes videos
about working on TV shows and movies
I've seen you in those thank you we've
got a big day ahead of us full of
surprises reveals and even a dash of
magic ooh we'll get some sneak peeks
hear from some of our favorite actors
and directors plus share tons of first
looks at some exciting new movies coming
into Netflix like day shift the vampire
action movie with Jamie Foxx I'm very
excited for that one plus Wendell and
wild the new stop-motion movie from
Henry Selleck and Jordan peel that's an
star combo right there exactly you're
going to get a nice deep dive on two
upcoming movies the first is the
action-packed The Gray Man and the
school for good and evil will be sitting
down with their cast and creators later
today cannot wait but first it's time
for some reveals let's Jump Right In The
Deep End with the Sea Beast going old
Kaiju fans and Loch Ness monster
conspiracy theorists are you ready to
get Kate I'm Karl Urban and I've got a
geeked week sneak peek at the trailer of
our new movie The Seabees I voiced Jacob
Holland a great legendary sea monster
hunter who Braves unknown waters on an
epic journey to find creatures so
ferocious it'll make history where the
map ends our Venture begins don't miss
the Sea Beast on Netflix July 8th it's
kinda hard to miss these sea beasts are
pretty freaking huge
there was a time when sea beasts would
ravage our Shores
and no ship was safe on the scene
but those days are over
today Valiant Warriors battle the beasts
Far Beyond the Horizon
you're Jacob Holland a weapon against
Nature's darkest desire and I'm joining
your crew oh no you ain't
[Applause]
[Music]
a monster
[Applause]
you stowed away I
yeah no I like this kid
we're dropping you off at the nearest
pool hunting ship ain't no place for a
kid but you joined the ship when you
were in the age
oh look at you now
that's not the same thing isn't it no
no
isn't
the drugs more thick with monsters
monsters don't want to eat us we're not
keeping it but he's so okay
you and I have a different idea of cute
just don't move
let's be going
I see a fire in her same fire I saw in
you the monsters I can handle we got it
right where we want it that one
she'll be the death of me
I swore I would do everything in my
power to keep people safe you can be a
hero and still be wrong
the ocean is sent us it's worse than
we'll send that right back
I've always wanted a pet that's not pet
that's I already named it let me guess
blue
[Music]
from Chris Williams the director of Big
Hero 6 and Moana comes the Epic animated
Adventure the Sea Beast badass main
character turns soft by the end of it no
I love that and I feel like Karl Urban
is like the perfect person to do that
perfect because the guy looks so
menacing but he's so Charming so
Charming yeah perfect voice yes
absolutely perfect voice in addition to
Carl Urban the Sea Beast has an All-Star
cast including zarus Angel hatar and
Jared Harris also Marianne John Baptiste
Dan Stevens and Kathy Burke we have a
never before seen poster from the film
nice yeah no I love it fortunately you
won't have to wait long to hit the high
seas with the Sea Beast it's drops on
Netflix July 8th that's so soon yeah
our next film is an exciting new project
from acclaimed Norwegian director let's
check out an exclusive first look at
troll
Stein
right
American company
released today
troll comes to us from Norway where we
get to encounter a gigantic creature
come to life and follow his
Misadventures as he heads towards Oslo I
feel like the trailer looks scarier than
that synopsis did not seem like the the
plot twist at the end is that he's good
it appears he is up to no good
um ruar utzag previously directed Tomb
Raider so I can't wait to see the
awesome action sequences we're sure to
get in troll I have no idea what to
expect neither do I but I'm excited and
also it's nice uh that we're getting a
nice International feature yeah because
they have such a different take on
action and it's so much fun to watch
very true check out Netflix film and
Netflix geeked on Twitter for all the
latest updates on this very exciting
project
foreign this next film has everything
comedy action Jamie Foxx and a
supernatural creature we haven't covered
yet vampires wow we're really getting
into all the mythical creatures I was
gonna say we have a kraken we have a
troll I don't know if it's a rock troll
or a regular troll and vampires Jimmy
Fox also mythical do you have a favorite
between I guess vampires or werewolves I
like myself a vampire story okay they're
a little sexier than uh trolls they are
yes we are talking about day shift a new
R-rated film from the team behind John
Wick oh sick yes they know there's gonna
be some action in this director JJ Perry
who is a stunt coordinator on everything
from John Wick to F9 is reuniting with
producer Chad stahelski uh he's the
director of John Wick and together
they're making a vampire movie unlike
anything I think we've ever seen yeah to
give us a taste of what's in store
here's a first look at some of the
action and stunt work and day shift
coming to Netflix this summer
yo what up it's Jamie Foxx you are not
preparing for dayship this is going to
be like something you've never seen
before
this movie has what I call eating
popcorn moments you know when you're
like oh
in this movie I'm in the business of
chasing down vampires and getting money
for fangs good energy guys here it comes
good friend of mine JJ Perry we started
his sentiment together way back in the
late 90s having done all the John Wick
films and then reading the script I
think JJ makes the shift to Fresh take I
love the idea of the vampires because it
takes himself a notch
oh no
no
no
JJ's taking some vampire mythology and
put it in Crazy situations of gunfights
and car chases and motorcycle chases
we're making something that you've never
seen before it's fun and the stuff that
you see is amazing and it's practical
oh the way JJ uses all of his stunt
women and men it's brilliant so I cannot
wait for people to get a dose of this
and find out how to kill
vampires right here on day shift
[Music]
that looks like so much fun that looks
like a lot of fun right off the bat
what's your biggest takeaway from that
the contortionist that freaked me out in
addition to Jamie Foxx day shift also
Stars Dave Franco and Snoop Dogg that is
crazy that is so fun did you ever think
you'd see Snoop Dogg hunting vampires in
your life I didn't and I didn't know
that I needed that yeah I do need it
up next we're talking about a spine
tingling mystery coming from Spain
Espana exciting are you a fan of the
mystery well you've been in a mystery I
am a mystery you are a mystery he's an
enigma really not
this new slasher is called el Club de
los lictorus criminalis it's got fans
really hyped and we have a special intro
from the cast check it out
is
foreign
[Laughter]
oh cool oh [ __ ] yeah Netflix
too far but yeah no that looks really
cool and I like that they don't really
give anything away they just kind of set
that spooky mood set in town here yeah
they should have given us flashlights
for this this opportunity guys yeah but
in this new movie a creepy clown starts
murdering the members of a college book
club one by one but they might not be as
innocent as they seem sounds fun yeah um
yeah who hasn't had a creepy clown chase
you and their and your friends yeah no
exactly they've been there I was gonna
say that was you know last Tuesday for
us be sure to check out El Club on
Twitter at Netflix geeked
three two one blast off
close enough uh we'll be checking out
the new Sci-Fi comedy blasted uh which
comes to us from Norway and is actually
inspired by a true life UFO event
yeah are you a big alien guy big alien
guy do we believe in aliens
yes to an extent I don't believe in like
those little green guys no like I I
think there's like a planet of maybe
like bacteria what about you
bacteria yeah absolutely definitely
bacteria out there that's not exciting
so let's get blasted yeah we've got an
exclusive trailer for blasted right here
for you at eat week
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wheelbar
okay aliens
foreign
follows a career obsessed workaholic
Sebastian and a laser tag Prodigy
Michael two childhood best friends who
are reunited for Sebastian's bachelor
party but when the bachelor party
stumbles head first into an alien
invasion it's up to Mikhail and
Sebastian to reunite as the Kick-Ass
laser tag Duo they once were and fight
back there's movies like hanging over
means Hot Fuzz with UFOs in Norway you
should be writing the synopsis these are
yeah it's pretty good that's good it's a
good one genuinely I'm sold
also Pataki is a certified action Queen
and her new movie Interceptor just hit
Netflix this past weekend in the film
Elsa plays a military expert in a Race
Against Time to save the station she
commands sounds like it's in good action
I would love myself to one day be a
certified action Queen
um it doesn't look like it's in the
cards just yet
but who knows the action sequences are
fantastic an Interceptor and Elsa is
here to give us a behind the scenes
sneak peek at how they brought these
epic stunts to life Elsa take it away
I'm Elsa Pataki and I can't wait to
share with you my new movie Interceptor
an Interceptor I play this amazing world
called JJ Collins it's very strong
independent Fierce woman that has to
beat everybody up
and I really I really enjoy doing it we
actually train really hard over six
months hip training gym weights getting
strong with an amazing team of stunned
people and stun coordinator we can like
almost like over 800 moves like
seriously of fights stay tuned as we
take you behind the scenes
foreign
action movie because I'd love to
challenge myself and when I read it I
was like I mean it was everything you
want an action movie
the death is a big action movie but the
whole story takes place in this
high-tech room we knew very early on
that the film would live and die on the
quality of its fights
that all depends on the actor how much
she can be taught how much she can learn
how much she can process and how much
she can deliver it fortunately our actor
is Elsa Pataki
Elsa Pataki his awesomeness personified
she got into physical shape for the
movie and we're talking Linda Hamilton
Terminator 2 fit she did months of fight
preparation she was with us every single
day and she would just keep asking for
more
Relentless she never gives up never
gives up ain't nobody like me but
everybody like me pretty girl swag in my
wrist stay icy there's six major fight
scenes with highly trained assassins and
our series single-handedly kicking every
single one of their asses
there's 800 beats of fight choreography
to learn
one thing that's very different in this
film from other action films is that
it's a female lead if you looked at the
characters that she's fighting side by
side you would say she's well and truly
outmatched but we move very differently
to men men carry a lot of weight in
their upper body and on their shoulders
and we carry it in our hips so she's
quick she's agile she gets around and in
between and she uses everything at her
disposal to to gain the upper hand she
uses the environment in a creative way
in every single fight scene
I had the best stunting so much fun just
like give me more I can take it anyway
we are setting up to shoot the leap of
faith in which Elsa swings one-handed
and jumps a 2.3 meter Gap under svx1
yeah
[Music]
it was hard work but I enjoy every
second of it by the end of this movie I
had put her through so much all these
fights hanging from one arm putting her
underneath the billowing clouds of a
rocket launcher you can't ask for any
more in a leading lady everybody else of
attack
she was so dedicated and so passionate
about how she wanted JJ to be portrayed
you know a strong female character that
kicked major ass
she was smiling through most of that
yeah what a beast uh Interceptor also
Stars Luke Bracey and features a cameo
from executive producer and Elsa's
husband in real life Chris Hemsworth and
I really just love to see him in things
we may be seeing Chris later in the show
hmm
from Aliens to action stars to infected
flesh-eating monsters
Hydro bradens folks our next title is
actually a brand new announcement let's
check out this next film from Japan
which is inspired by a hit horror manga
series
hello geeked week
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
is on 100 bucket list of the Dead is
about Akira a young man whose dull life
is invigorated when a zombie apocalypse
hits his town yeah we're very excited to
also be sharing a first look at Zone 100
bucket list of the dead that's it
honestly
this looks very fun I like how well lit
it is
um I feel like a lot of times zombie
movies will try to go into night and
like up that scare tactic but this looks
fun he's on a bicycle he could be
enjoying himself
no probably not the original manga
series was penned by haruaso and
illustrated by Katara Takata and here is
our zom100 star A.G akaso who's playing
Akira very exciting news that this
beloved manga is coming to Netflix
[Music]
straw head goofy is sitting down with
the rooster Brothers to reveal an
exclusive clip from the new action movie
The Great mix and later Tessa netting
catches up with the stars of the new
Paul speak movie the school for good and
evil today's geek week programming is
literally just getting started
next up we're taking a look at Wendell
and wild now this film comes from the
delightfully Wicked Minds of Henry
Selleck and Jordan peel from The
Nightmare Before Christmas to Coraline
Henry Selleck has created some of the
most iconic stop-motion animated movies
of all time yeah no for sure and did he
traumatize you as a child well of course
combining that with the hilarious Duo
Keegan Michael Key and Jordan peel in
the starring roles this is truly like
genuinely one of my most anticipated
movies of the year we've got director
Henry Selleck here with a sneak peek
from Wendell and Wild
it's geek tweak geek tweak don't forget
your eyeballs when the wild will be
there get geeked
out
[Music]
oh
hmm
Bears above
[Music]
Wendell and wild is a tale about two
demon Brothers Wendell and wild they
enlist the aid of 13 year old Kat
Elliott who's a tough teen with a load
of guilt and she's voiced by lyric Ross
and she summons them to the land of the
living but what cat demands in return
leads to a brilliantly bizarre comedic
Adventure like no other an animated
fantasy that defies the law of life and
death all told through the handmade
Artistry of stop-motion attention
details like mind-blowing I was gonna
say that's really cool like I love how
like she appears around the corner and
her hair moves a little bit like it I
can't imagine like how painstakingly
tough it is to make the stop motion also
had you ever seen Henry Selleck before
like his face yeah never he seems like a
nice guy yeah which is very surprising
from the stuff he makes I'm excited to
see what key and peel how they fit into
this universe Gwendolyn Wilde also
features The Voice talents of Angela
Bassett Ving Rhames and James Hong what
a cast no it's like it's genuinely hard
to believe it's been 13 years since
Henry Selleck's last movie Coraline was
released that's wild no isn't it like it
genuinely like 13 dwindling someone say
that's pretty good
our next title is spiderhead starring
Chris Hemsworth oh the best way I can
describe spider head is like Maniac
meets squid game with just a dash of
Black Mirror and like that yeah so I
feel like we're gonna get some like cool
sci-fi elements and it might get dark
let's check it out yeah
hello again sorry I'm late for strip
Misty
not late at all
[Music]
that's spider-head
you're proud of our work
your presence in this facility while
technically a punishment is a privilege
where have you been drug study in
science we have to explore the unknown
they've been testing me up and down a
lot weirder stuff than usual it's New
Frontier stuff here
before we begin I need your permission
to administer 10 40. this place can
really mess with your head and grip on
acknowledge drip on acknowledge
acknowledge acknowledge
let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
where are we getting this
[Music]
whoa
this doesn't feel right
time to worry about Crossing Lines was a
lot of lines ago
our work will save lives not just one
life many lives
we're making the world a better place
is redemption and this is how are you
gonna find it
we're selling peace into harmony itself
[Applause]
beautiful people get away with too much
and I say that having benefited myself
from time to time
foreign
[Music]
Chris Hemsworth here apologies I
couldn't be there in person hope you're
doing well I'm very excited to show you
an exclusive look at my new film spider
head it is a futuristic Thriller set in
a state-of-the-art Penitentiary where
inmates have an opportunity to have
reduced sentences by volunteering for
experiments involving mood altering and
mind altering drugs and this is all
under the guise that it's for the
betterment and benefit of mankind but as
you can imagine it's not quite the case
check it out it's Unique and exciting
hope you enjoy
sorry I'm late for strip Misty
I'm gonna retire the day you call me
Steve not late at all
Heather on the other hand
the devil sorry
[Music]
all right
oh how rude with me yeah Jeff Heather
Heather Jeff
for the record either prior to or during
your incarceration here at spiderhead
have you two ever spoken
ever interacted in any way
no
so what do you think
who are you asking yeah I'm asking both
of you let's start with Jeff
seems nice
you like that word but no I mean how
attractive is she
Heather can you shut up please I'm
asking Jeff Jeff how's she looking
at one to ten
um
yeah she's a seven and a half
and Heather
he's all right five on a good day
did you give her honesties no I would
have to ask you know that I'm just kind
of a [ __ ] oh
well then I'd like to change my vote to
an eight
all right uh Jeff Heather can I have
your permission to administer N40 drip
on
acknowledge
oh yeah
acknowledge
you
[Music]
uh come on guys words words words okay
uh she's starting to look pretty good
I'm like
yeah she's she's looking
really
really good
uh same
yeah
pump up the verbalist let's get him
talking
[Music]
don't tell us tell each other
you're you're stunning you're gorgeous I
don't I'm so sorry I don't know why I
didn't see it before the gym was
beautiful I think I've ever seen in my
life
thank you
yeah I could
what Jeff
you weren't lying with the black mirror
or the maniac the squid game no like I
hadn't really known much about it going
in but that looks really cool looks very
cool I don't know where they're gonna go
with this and this Chris Hemsworth a
good guy is he a bad guy I don't know
I'd kind of like to see him be the bad
guy yeah because I feel like he always
plays like the good charming type and
it'd be kind of cool to see like that
dark like yeah like this little app
thing what are the ulterior motives
joining him in this statcast are Miles
Teller and journey Smollett and well you
know the soundtrack is
beautiful yeah the Doobie Brothers
wonderful touch whoever decided to put
that in there good job fighter head is
coming to Netflix on June 17th oh that's
really soon be sure to follow Netflix
film and Netflix geeked on Tick Tock for
all the updates and that's it for
today's geeked programming oh wait a
minute hold on we're not done just yet
no no we couldn't let this year's geek
week pass without an update from this
special guest
hey geekweek I'm Zack Snyder and I'm
Sophia boutella we're on the set of our
big new movie Rebel moon it's a giant
Space Opera with visual effects sci-fi
fantasy Crazy Action right yeah about a
bunch of Misfits that come together
Against All Odds you've been training
hard yeah for months now and we just
started shooting and it's so far awesome
we have an amazing cast exciting
costumes and makeup and characters that
you won't believe you're looking at yeah
some aliens and all sorts of craziness
and really proud of the team that I have
working they're doing an incredible job
so really for me it's a dream come true
so thank you geek geek oh wait before I
go keep your eyes peeled there's going
to be a bunch of stuff we're going to be
dropping along the way content maybe
some videos some stuff from on set so
keep your eyes up for that and enjoy
thank you geek tweak thank you
well that's exciting I was gonna say
that looks really cool he also is able
to Wrangle an amazing cast for like
every movie he does somehow which is
like kudos to him right because he has
that appeal he does have that appeal in
Rebel Moon a peaceful Colony on the edge
of the Galaxy he finds itself threatened
by the armies of the tyrannical Regent
belisarius I don't know what that means
but I'm intrigued they dispatch a young
woman with a mysterious past to seek out
Warriors from neighboring planets to
help them take a stand I'd like to
imagine she goes to each planet walks
into like a bar and is like I'm
assembling a team probably a better
execution though I think she'd give it
with like much more oomph as opposed to
my come on guys like let's go we're
gonna make a team yeah and one of them's
like no I'm not doing it and then you're
like no I would immediately give up
every Moon I protect conquered Zach
would have loved to be here today but as
you can see he's a little busy he's a
little busy building his epic adventure
I mean a little offended like how busy
can he actually be
Bill and talk Show and Zack Snyder well
he does at least love us enough to send
us a special message from the set of
Rebel Moon he's also hard at work on a
few other Netflix projects Army of the
Dead lost Vegas and Twilight of the Gods
and uh Netflix geeked we'll have more
news on those coming soon heck yeah okay
but was that actually everything
well technically there is more up next
is a panel for the Russo Brothers latest
film The Gray Man which stars Ryan
Gosling Chris Evans and on it to armas
and a special look for this school for
good and evil and a discussion with the
cast but actually that's it for us so
make sure to keep watching each week all
week long for even more releases
surprises and everything geeked
peace bye bye
it is movie night
in here there's the Great Big World
you can go places your dreams can't
dream up
or see things that give your nightmares
nightmares
[Music]
Hallelujah
[Music]
and here you can make your Escape
I already don't like you right back at
you sunshine
[Music]
here mystery Sparks extraordinary
Adventure the real mystery is why
everyone's talking to them I thought
that was my thing
in here you never know where the world
will take you
look on that Court you have to think I
am the best
[Music]
and here the party never stops
oh that's false I got something to do in
the morning so it kind of does
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
in here you can make an incredible
discovery
[Applause]
feel like a kid again wanna see
something cool
here is the Great Big World
and every night is movie night
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's geek week
Mama let's go we're late do I have to
your grandson's birthday only happens
once a year so does geek tweak
panel starts in 15.
sorry it's geeked week
Netflix geeked week 2022 June 6th to
10th
[Music]
what's up geeked week it's Juju AKA
Straw Hat goofy your movie guy on Tick
Tock and if you follow me you probably
know it's no surprise that it's one of
my dreams to be sitting down with the
directors of the new Netflix Blockbuster
The Gray Man
Joe Anthony Russo how are you guys doing
this again it's a dream of mine but I
want to know how you're doing right now
great this is also a dream of ours yeah
it's great to see you again to me great
to see you they remember guys talk about
that we met like three years ago and
they heard me screaming at an Avengers
end game a screener and I guess I've
made an impression you were wearing a
Miles Morales uh hoodie
they're giving me street cred so make
sure y'all make sure y'all know about
that but no thank you for coming to the
spot man Netflix geeked we're here uh
but let's talk about some of what you've
done leading into the gray man so you've
made some of the biggest films ever
we're talking Infinity War Winter
Soldier Civil War you me and Dupree the
paintball episodes and Community you
guys are just crushing it on everything
that you're doing what was it like doing
this next challenge what led you to
doing something like the gray man we
love action films I mean we were Geeks
growing up uh cinephiles we loved
everything pop culture we love movies we
love television we're playing video
games and we had voracious appetites we
do and we we watch stuff and play stuff
constantly and then we dissect stuff and
talk about it and we had things that we
loved in common things that one of us
would love and the other didn't that
we'd argue about and you know so action
films were always a constant with the
two of us I think what we love about it
is the sort of the you know the high
level choreography that goes into a high
degree of difficulty that's involved in
making an action movie it's a lot of
non-verbal uh storytelling uh moments in
an action film I think one of our
favorite things in filmmaking is just
being able to shift gears on the
audience you know you want to give
people a ride where they can't expect
what's going to happen next we also love
the thematics that go with the sort of
characters that are in death defying
situations and how they stare down death
and how that defines who they are as
people and as a character and so those
were always some of my favorite films of
seeing these you know really intense
characters and characters are the best
at what you know in their particular
craft at what they did or had it had a
certain level of skills that you know
allowed them to um to survive but just
barely and that's what the gray man's
about to answer the Thrills I love how
we did yeah can you tell me a little bit
about the gray man and like what the
story entails well the gray man is about
an agent in the CIA and he's in a
special program called the Sierra
program that takes prisoners of a
certain profile and basically offers
them a way out of prison and wipes their
identity turns them into a ghost and
trains them to be the best assassins in
the world that's a scary Prospect we
really think about that right you know
people who don't have anything to lose
yeah you take everything away from them
and say here and that's it he's trained
the reason he's called The Gray Man this
you know it's his job to disappear his
identity but also to disappear in
circumstances where he's been sent in to
kill someone he has to move in and out
without being noticed so in the world of
Secrets and spies he is the most secret
because nobody literally knows who he is
you know I feel like you know with 007
people kind of have an inkling of who he
is but here they're free to pretty much
live in the shadows and be great and
they uh push their identity down so it's
an interesting character because the
journey in the film is about identity
it's about him discovering who he is and
what it is that he wants because you
know he spent a large portion of life in
jail and then the second portion of his
life working for the CIA against his
will so he really has never had a moment
in his life to Define who he is as a
person and that's what the film is about
it's very interesting well uh keep it on
the topic of like just the gray man and
just this theme of reuniting right like
we've reunited on this set right that's
right right but the great man sees you
reuniting with screenwriters that you've
worked with on numerous occasions
Christopher Marcus and Stephen mcfeely
right what was it like collaborating
with them again and being going from
Superhero Blockbusters to now this
action-packed spy Thriller well we
developed an amazing relationship with
Chris and Steve through the four films
that we made with them at Marvel we
spent about seven eight years working
together on those movies and as we were
all sort of moving on past uh endgame we
were forming a company called agbo Joe
and I fans of The Tick Tock yeah we
dabble we dabble and then uh we asked
them to be our partners in it so we now
have a company together where uh the
four of us basically can work together
and create original material develop
things that we're passionate about so we
have a very thick relationship with them
and our work with them on the gray man I
think was just an extension of of of a
great range of of work and experiences
that we have together that's really cool
it's all about it's all about putting
that team together right that's right
the collaboration is everything I mean
especially when we're working at the
scale this level of ambition and
projects that are just complicated you
know we ants and I like to work a lot so
you know collaboration is the essential
nature of of who we are as a directing
team has been for 25 years and that
extends out into other key collaborators
in our lives like Marcus mcphaily okay
well speaking of like collaborators and
putting that team together you're
working with Chris Evans again
reuniting with him again another week
Chris Evans well we all do
right when when you were done with like
the whole Avengers era working with
Chris Evans there uh was there previous
conversations during or maybe a little
bit after of doing something
non-avengers or Marvel related or were
you in the middle of crafting this film
and saying he would be great for this we
trust him for sure yeah everyone who
works on Marvel is very grateful that
they worked tomorrow because it affords
you incredible opportunity from The
Branding exposure and you know the
international visibility you have the
bank ability to you know Chris can get
things made because he's Chris Evans and
Marvel is a huge part of that but it's
also nice after you've done 10 years
doing one kind of thing to go do a bunch
of different other things you know and
you know it's fun about the gray man is
this is brand new uh um IP it's new
storytelling uh um it's you know based
on a book but you know it's uh it hasn't
been in you know film or TV before uh
and Chris is you know at a point in his
career where he wants to take risks I
mean of all the amazing actors we worked
with in the MCU our longest
collaboration was with Chris Evans we
started with him and we finished with
him exactly so we spent a lot of time
talking with all those actors about
other ideas you had plenty of downtime
in the filmmaking process to sort of
explore one another and and and sort of
feel out what's interesting to them and
certainly to be able to offer a role
like this to Chris was a thrill for us
because it's so far away yeah from what
he did as Captain America absolutely and
Chris is an amazing actor he became very
well known and iconic for his
performance as Captain America but he
can do remarkable things as an actor in
very different styles very different
tones and you'll see that in this movie
for sure the range on that man is like
insane and underrated I will add too
because without question I think he's a
very technically gifted actor and being
technically sound allows you to take
chances and gives you great range
because you have the technique to
prepare properly for that role yeah and
he's very good at that he's very
disciplined and he's very hard working
he's also got great instincts he
understands the camera he understands
how people are going to read what it is
that he's doing he's self-aware he
almost has like a third eye that can see
him performing you know so is really
gifted that way and I think that affords
them the opportunity to take these kinds
of risks yes that's awesome because
Chris you know I I find and I will cite
forever to this day that one of his
greatest performances is him as Lucas
Lee and Scott program versus the world
yeah that's true a villain turn which
again you guys kind of took his image as
Captain America very morally upright
very kind of like Stern and then you
flip them to being a villain here it's
so rare to find an actor of his caliber
who is willing to play a villain and
wants to play a villain on screen that
reminds us of Fonda and Once Upon a Time
in the West where he took this sort of
All-American
reputation and put it at risk by playing
a basically a child killer Evan's doing
the same thing here he's playing like a
ferocious psychopath highly entertaining
very sarcastic but you know does a lot
of terrible things in the movie uh and
uh and you know that that's risky yeah
yeah very far from Captain America very
far so going from Chris you landed on
Ryan Gosling now tell me a little bit
more about what went into that choice of
saying Ryan's our guide for that the
connection between the character and
Ryan Joe and I felt very early on uh
before we ever approached Ryan about it
it just Ryan is a master of of
minimalism and subtlety he knows how to
convey a very complex inner life through
by doing very little as an actor it's
remarkable but he can be extremely
charismatic at the same time while he's
doing that
um and that's really what this character
needed this character is a very hidden
cloaked careful character that doesn't
waste any energy does it does it move if
he doesn't have to because everything's
being conserved in case he needs it and
when he needs it yeah Ryan's approach to
Performance is somewhat similar to the
gray man's approach to living the actual
characters approach the living in a wild
way but course the character's journey
in the movie The Gray Man starts from
that place of being very hidden and
through the movie through his
relationships in the movie he's forced
to come out he's forced to commit at an
emotional level to the people around him
and the people that he cares about and
so of course Ryan uh you know again with
that who his ability to create a very
complex and compelling inner life that
just kind of blossoms as the movie goes
on and uh he was he was he's the dream
actor he also has a very witty and
quirky sense of humor yeah and the movie
has a very quirky tone at points so you
know he checks every box yeah for this
character I mean Ryan's just spectacular
yeah I love I love how you talked about
his ability to kind of mask a lot and do
a lot with very very little you know it
definitely takes me back to his
performance and drive right you know how
he's he doesn't really have a lot of
dialogue there it's literally just like
an internal type of Master minimum you
know and he he crushes it here with that
with that same like sense submit as well
it's amazing well guys we can't talk
about bringing like this badass story to
life without hearing from those two
leads that we just talked about Ryan
Gosling and Chris Evans so we called
with them on set to hear in their own
words about bringing this movie to life
let's take a look right now the rooster
Brothers reached out to me about being
in this film and it was really exciting
because you know I've always loved
action movies to get to be a part of
something like that was really exciting
and and to be able to do with the russos
was even better being able to work with
them again was a real treat with those
two they could ask me to do anything and
I'd do it I'm excited for an action
movie a true action movie to have so
many good characters and so many good
performances all the fight sequences
were challenging they were all very
different from one another we tried to
find a way with the action in every
situation we were in to really you know
be in the space that we were going to be
shooting and then find a way to really
use that environment The Roosters they
know every detail of action why the
score works or why the lighting worked
or just the speeding up of frames and
everything they they're they're
incredibly attentive to the detail
specifically with action
man so how does it feel having those two
guys speak so highly of you the entire
time hey we paid everybody
they're happy with their deal no they
they're look at their amazing people and
here's the thing about both of them they
are actors but they are also filmmakers
and I think that's why we connect so
well is because they are people who are
paying attention to not only what
they're doing as a performer on the set
but they're paying attention to what
everybody else is doing and how they
relate to them as a collaborator on the
set and that's the dream kind of actor
we love working with that kind of actor
who is is as conscious of the people
around them as they are of themselves
yeah and it's it's fun to see uh how
much they're observing and how much
they're they're sort of following in our
process but I can tell you Joe and I
feel that on set working with them a lot
of similarities in the way that we work
um Anthony because we're a duo we have
to talk out everything so we get to set
our process is really discipline very
prescribed focused we are available to
improv because but that's because we're
so prepared so we're okay throwing out
part of the plan because we know can
always fall back on it if we need to and
both those actors are very similar to us
we're thorough they're prepared they're
you know they're they're very uh sound
Technical Training and you know and we
all like to work the same way so we all
had a great experience together that's
really cool and again I think that goes
back to what you were saying like that
team of collaboration and just everyone
having that Spirit of wanting to create
something cool something awesome
something good and it's really great to
hear that those two have that same kind
of like mindset that you two have which
is like pretty awesome uh I want to get
a little bit further into uh specific
things that you've collaborated on so
you described this film as nine set
pieces which is insane because I feel
like movies other movies
probably literally because there's so
many things going on we talked about it
right before the camera started rolling
but can you describe exactly what you
meant by the nine action set piece
describing it as nine set pieces yeah I
mean this movie what was so compelling
about the book is that there's a the
conceit at the heart of the film is a
character on the run and Lloyd is this
sort of this very Savvy Hunter of men
and uh Sierra six he's played by
um Ryan's character is impossible to
catch you know that's really the
exercise of the film uh and for us it
was you know we love action so we're
like you know what how can we push it to
its limits how can we create something
incredibly propulsive for the audience
and you know highly watchable I mean
there's just why something like
everything everywhere all at once works
by that level of absurdism works is
because it's married to genre right in
your brainwise genre works for you as
your brain can track genre it has an
understanding of it there's certain
rules that exist within it that then
allow for that absurdism to be married
to in a way that creates a very
satisfying experience that's
compulsively watchable we're doing the
same thing here where we're playing with
tones you know there's a level of
quirkiness to this movie that is unique
for Action films but there's also an
intense amount of action we're smashing
those things together and trying to
create a you know a highly enjoyable
very you know compulsively watchable
experience for the audience it's because
of what's what we like
um you know and uh um so I think uh you
know hopefully it's uh it's going to be
you know feel like a throwback action
film a lot of ways for people I can tell
the the geekiness of how you describe
this like I could tell there's so much
inspiration from film from films past
that like really informed like the
action set pieces here and everything
like that you also did that with Winter
Soldier throwing it back to the 70s spy
Thrillers of the past as well but you
film so many action scenes over the
years with Chris obviously so he's kind
of indoctrinated into your style of
action filming uh but Ryan hasn't
necessarily done action like this before
like we've seen a Blade Runner 2049
we've seen them in things like drive but
this very different action than what you
guys do and again you guys have your
very unique it's physical it's kinetic
it's exact dynamic you know we ask after
actors to train very hard for it we like
the actors that execute most of the
action as long as it's safe and you want
your brain going on that's a stud player
so we do push them very hard uh and Ryan
took to it like a fish to water he
really he really worked his ass off he's
in incredible shape for this movie I
think the best shape of his uh his life
and and he understood that you know what
it is that you do with your body in an
action film and performs in a lot of
ways who you are as a character yeah
that's what ants and I like about it
there's almost a it's like a cave
painting in a lot of ways right like
it's it's demonstrative in the way that
it communicates uh to an audience
actually the the action genre so uh and
I think he he really understood that and
he painted a portrait of a character
physically that has been imprisoned and
had understood you know
that his only value in prison would be
looking out right and then took that
it's the only way he's going to survive
and then carry that forward into being
an agent and so his body scar covered
and he's chiseled he affects the size of
his neck so that's a little subtle
things that it did to give his
performance this quality of like an
ex-con right right you don't want to
have you know all the show and no go
right that's right he has the show right
and as we're about to see it a little
bit he has a plenty of goals you guys
brought an exclusive clip with you guys
from
get the people excited about what
they're about to see like what exactly
are we about to see right now I think
this is a real hype clip because this is
a very special moment this is Gosling
versus Evans that's the first time that
those two characters made the uh
Unstoppable force and they movable
object crashing into each other uh and
uh you know the movie really is a mono
Amano and it's it's Unique to get a film
like this because uh it's hard to get a
movie star to play a villain uh and uh
and Evans again being at that point in
his career wanting to take risks you now
have these two enormous movie stars
going head-to-head with each other and
this would give you a taste of what
that's like it's really cool that well
I'm excited to see that to be honest
let's take a look at it right now
foreign
[Applause]
it leans Lloyd
where's the drive
yeah
is that in
over here
nice try pumpkin I'm so sure you why
do you want my foot in your ass oh [ __ ]
Smiler
looks like an 11. who's this lunatic
yeah Lloyd let's go I'm good let's go
sounded like a question
you know I was over here thinking to
myself like at some point if you're a
henchman you just gotta drop the gun and
say he's got hurry up my guys let me
just go I'm glad you brought that out I
was gonna say as you can see it's not
not a very violent movie uh yeah it's
like no no no the action is absolutely
awesome though like seeing Ryan Gosling
like again he did the work he's mowing
down these dudes left and right but
what's also very striking is that you
know I think you guys have already kind
of perfected this art is that not only
is it badass it's really really funny
and that's very hard to kind of like
balance with you know having a badass
moment and then throwing in a joke to
maybe compromise that but you don't
compromise it it's really just a tedet
between Ryan Gosling and Chris Evans can
you talk about it I think Joe and I like
to play with tone in very sort of odd
mixtures and the reason we do that is
because you know the audience doesn't
know where you're gonna go next you know
the part part of that scene we just
watched is really brutal and kind of
shocking absolutely and then all of a
sudden it twists and can become very
witty and sort of of sort of strange at
a character level yeah uh and then the
dexterity the the ability to be able to
Pivot between those kinds of ideas as
filmmakers and as performers is
difficult and it's something we like to
play with because it's just exciting to
watch yeah yeah the thing is is like the
two of them are like you said assassins
at the top of their game like Masters in
their craft and so there's almost an
edge of of competitiveness in the in the
fight right they're they're super
confident in what they're doing so it's
almost like that trash talk of like I'm
gonna get you and you're gonna know that
I'm gonna get you and I'm gonna enjoy it
and that's like the cool thing about
seeing that humor come through and
that's what you can kind of see how that
informs the action scenes now that we
got the fans hyped for the gray man they
still have about a month and a half to
wait until the movie actually comes out
uh do you guys have any last words to
help tide them over until the movie is
released
oh say this we've talked a lot about
Ryan Gosling and Chris Evans but you
don't have to also have to remember
there's Anna De armas Billy Bob Thornton
Alfre Woodard reggae Jean page
it's uh Jessica henwick the cast is is
dynamite in this movie and there's a lot
of places to go other than those two two
guys uh up front that's awesome I'm
really excited for editor Armisen
Dimension like between the two of those
like seeing him like this is his
introduction to Hollywood right that's
right he's his very first Hollywood it's
fantastic he's a huge star over and over
in India as well so I'm really excited
to see him getting that but Joe Anthony
thank you so much for taking the time to
sit here and talk to me about just
movies and this film in general like so
excited for the great man so excited for
everybody to see it can't wait to find
out what our next epic reunion will be
awesome man looking forward to it all
right for those of you at home there's
plenty more in store for the gray man
before it comes out on Netflix July 22nd
so be sure to follow Netflix geek and
Netflix film from all the the updates
and also don't forget to follow your
movie guide Straw Hat Goofy on Tick Tock
Instagram YouTube just follow me
everywhere just you see it because
that's it for us here but up next you're
going to be hearing from the stars of
school for good and evil and getting a
sneak peek at the upcoming coffee
fantasy film before we let you go though
let's take a look at the badass Gray Man
trailer one last time
what do you know about the Sierra
program
Reckless Mystery Men you guys sent in
when you can officially send anyone else
it's a great man
employed
I got an urgent locate and destroy that
could be fun the man's got some street
cred
[Music]
you hurt
I mean my ego's a little bruised
and have something they really want
what's Your Gut it's going to be my
funeral you're going to next you want to
make an omelette
you gotta kill some people
you must be Lloyd what gave it away the
trash Dash it just it leans Lloyd
I'm about to put a hit so big on your
boy's head I've been eating his most
loyal allies don't hesitate to drop a
knife every grade a wet team from here
I'll be lying for The Prestige of
killing the infamous Sierra suits
I can kill anybody
foreign
[Music]
action can be sort of a dangerous
Endeavor we all want to push the
envelope we all want to try things that
haven't been done before the way that we
work on action is a layered process
because we use action to advance story
and character
[Music]
Marvel has done incredible things for a
lot of people because once you're that
level of awareness for making those
movies you can kind of do anything you
want
[Music]
which is why we ended up shooting the
most amount of action that we've ever
shot in a single film
[Music]
foreign
Army handles the missiles Captain
Collins reporting sir
everyone wants to be anywhere but here
we're the only Interceptor platform
protecting from a nuclear missile attack
we have a situation unauthorized missile
removal
what's going on up there
seven terrorists seized our vessel and
they tried to take the command center
killed everyone else on this vessel when
we control 16 nuclear missiles I need to
disable your command center so I will be
getting into that room you want this
room
come and get it
[Applause]
we don't have time to evacuate cities
[Music]
did you just stab that dude in the eye
with your gun
I'm the one in charge you want to get
out of here alive it's not going so well
for you is it
your plan for every possible outcome
but you couldn't plan for me
Pogo
get off the couch wanna go for a walk
hey buddy come on fetch
hobo what's this come on to Papa
Pogo we all want to watch geek week
Netflix geeked week 2022 June 6 to 10.
foreign
[Music]
not late at all
[Music]
that's spider-head
of our work
[Music]
your presence in this facility while
technically a punishment is a privilege
where have you been drug study in
science we have to explore the unknown
they've been testing me up and down a
lot weirder stuff than usual this new
frontier stuff here
again I need your permission to
administer 1040. this place can really
mess with your head
acknowledge drip on acknowledge
acknowledge yeah acknowledges
let's do this
this doesn't feel right
time to worry about Crossing Lines was a
lot of lines ago
[Music]
save lives
not just one life many lives
[Music]
we're making the world a better place
what you want is redemption and this is
how are you gonna find it
we're selling peace into harmony itself
foreign
beautiful people get away with too much
and I say that having benefited myself
from time to time
[Music]
what's up geeked week my name is Tessa
netting and I am so excited to bring you
some updates around one of the Netflix
movies that I cannot wait to see this
year the school for good and evil pause
for dramatic effect today we're gonna
have some never before seen sneak peeks
from this new Fantastical film from
director Paul fee coming up for you real
soon but first I am so excited to be
sitting down with the two stars of the
school for good and evil Sophia Wiley
who plays Agatha and Sophia and Caruso
who plays Sophie hi guys hey are you
guys so excited yeah I'm so so excited I
can't stop smiling I'm literally like on
top of the world unlike Agatha I guess
that's not a Smiler yeah when was the
last time you saw each other like was it
when you wrapped filming yeah because
I'm from Arizona and then she's from New
York so we're never in the same place
whenever we're not filming so now you
guys are back together reunion
so nice so for the uninitiated for the
ones that aren't fans yet uh how would
you describe like the school for good
and evil and your characters well I play
Agatha she's very dry and kind of grumpy
and she's grown up in this Village
called Gabaldon where she's basically
been characterized as a witch so she's
an outcast nobody likes her she lives
alone in a cemetery with her mom despite
all of this and how she's treated she
still has such a loving and caring heart
and the person that she I think loves
the most is her best friend Sophie their
friendship throughout the film is I
think the most prominent part it's it's
so beautiful and you can see that it
perseveres past all of the chaos that
ensues yeah we think that Agatha is the
Witch and we think that I am the good
girl and little do they know some things
go down it gets a little rough but when
people ask me what it's about
I say it's about friendship and seeing
eye to eye
seeing the good and the bad in each
other and accepting it and loving each
other and it's about discovering
both sides of yourself it's not just
about discovering that you're beautiful
as we have a lot of themes of that in
the book it's also about discovering
that you're evil you're kind of ugly and
it's kind of bad but like it's in
everybody everybody's got a little bit
of both so it's the balance of those and
friendship which
we already have it was pretty easy on
screen to have it because we immediately
connected so fans got their first sneak
peek at the school for good and evil
earlier this year when we saw a bit of
Agatha in action at Netflix films 2022
movie preview and let me tell you they
lost their minds what did that response
mean to you seeing their reaction and
knowing that you are Agatha I was so
happy to see that the fans of the books
were accepting of both myself and Sophia
Ann as our characters because I know how
much fans books care because I am a book
fan and so when I see my favorite book
being turned into a movie or a TV show I
want to know who are these people going
to be they have my precious love in
their hands and it really is like a life
or death situation but I'm really glad
that they're liking it so far oh they
are so excited we put the call out
actually to some fans for some questions
and the Netflix geeked Community they
showed up so first up from lore889 on
Twitter they want to know would you guys
be an ever or never yourselves oh were
you 100 know we know the answer go ahead
why don't you okay do you want to say
mine and I'll say yours oh yeah on the
count of three yeah okay okay so I'm
gonna say what Sophia Ann is and you say
I am well yes okay okay one two three
hundred percent princess over here
100 and you're not like a villain but
you just are like a baddie like you just
walk into every room and you command it
I remember like that was something I
noticed during our audition I was like
oh gosh I think she already booked the
role like I had no clue whether we were
both auditioning together or if I was
just auditioning by myself and she was
had already booked it because you were
so calm and collected and you just knew
that you had it because you she is
Sophie in the walk into a room with that
kind of confidence or nothing's gonna
work out for you in this life you've
been walking through and I'm like got
this yeah I think I think Sophie's kind
of got that too she's like excuse me
this is my world and your outfits
reflect that perfectly yeah I know we
weren't sure what we were gonna wear
today you said black and white good and
evil yep good and evil you guys nailed
it really so uh Laura on Instagram wants
to know what was it like putting on
those in incredible costumes who's going
to talk about the corsets first
honestly I think you had the worst with
the corsets every outfit was the best it
was the best yes but there were days
you can't breathe I liked it though I
was like anymore my poor dresser her
hands were hurting for nothing to pull
the thing so tight but was this very
Sophie she would have you know it would
be cinched to the gods so yeah so it was
the costumes were amazing I mean really
transforming and it was such a
collaborative process getting to help
like create them and really yeah I've
never really had a more collaborative
costume design experience so in
pre-production before we were even like
having fittings I had a call with the
costume design and she showed me like
all these ideas I was like oh we see
I've already started a Pinterest board
and she goes I have a board share it
with me so we shared our board and we
had half of the same things on our
boards so we text all the time and I'm
always sending her like new ideas the
costumes were so collaborative and Paul
feig is wants to let you have your
essence on everything so the costume
screw characters but they also scream
like us as individuals yeah I think it
had a pretty similar experience I had
done like a zoom call a couple Zoom
calls with Renee and I was just filling
every idea that I had and I actually
took a lot of inspiration from
richardton because I I'm obsessed with
that show I had so many things pinned
and so many ideas and she was so
accepting and so so receptive and it was
very strange going into some of my first
fittings and trying on these princess
dresses and being like how am I supposed
to act like I hate this I literally
every single dress I put on I told them
I'm gonna piss my pants like it was that
was my my verbiage because I didn't have
any other way to describe how excited I
was it was like literally a dream come
true yeah I'm in a potato sack for first
part of the film but there's a certain
point where we take a turn and my
costumes are epic for the rest of the
movie so here's a question we got over
and over again have you guys read the
school for good and evil and were you
guys fans of the books like before you
got cast once you got cast did you read
any I had had a meeting with some
wonderful producers and they told me
that they were making this huge film and
they were telling me the summary in the
storyline and I was like the whole time
I was thinking I know this like I've
heard this somewhere and so after the
meeting I go on to my Goodreads account
look at my to read list and it's the
first book there I was planning on
reading it I finished the first one and
as I booked the role and was about to
start filming I was going to read the
second and third and then I was like
wait
don't do it don't do it yourself you
don't need to know everything that's
going to happen because then you're
going to start playing into all of that
so I had to literally restrain myself
I'd known about it for a long time and I
didn't get around to reading it until I
was you know signing on to do the show
and I didn't at first I thought
I really want to read this because what
is it going to do to what I was already
planning to do with the character
and I'm glad of course I read it like
how how could I not I had to read the
book and I loved it it's amazing and
I've sort of cherry-picked the things
that I feel about the character that I
could best represent I started reading
the second one I was like don't get
ahead of yourself I like how you both
had to like restrain yourself you're
like not yet not yet yeah so Zoe smiley
face on YouTube asks what line in the
books or in your scripts said by your
characters resonated with you the most
you're asking me to remember my lines
you go first a line that I love where
Professor dovey has just shown Agatha
that she is truly beautiful that this
perception that she has of herself that
she's created because of what people
have told her is actually all false and
she says to her you've been beautiful
all along there was no magic needed to
make you this way I really thought that
was such a beautiful message to show
that we all have this inner beauty about
us and it does not matter what we look
like on the outside or what people tell
us we are we are all beautiful and we
don't need anything to change and fix
that to make it more that's such a sweet
moment a key moment yeah we were talking
about beauty and I just thought there's
a bit where I go beauty is a full-time
job
it is it's like it's a full-time job
that's just like a side thought but the
important one I think and I'm saying I
don't want to be evil and she says kind
of what Devi said which is like you're
not and I Grumble a little bit and then
you say We'll always have each other
and that's the whole like Point kind of
it's like the best part of the whole
movie because what's better than a best
friend
nothing or just being accepted for
exactly who you are exactly and so
you're not you're human exactly we don't
need to be characterized as anything but
just human beings
so we can't talk about bringing this
beloved story to life without also
talking to the school for good and evil
Authority thank you I'm so excited to be
here with these two empresses
empresses wow someone talk to us for a
bit about the process of adapting this
book to film like what were you most
excited to see brought to life I mean to
me it's such a part of my soul I spent
10 years kind of building this world so
I never even received of the possibility
that it would become real you know and I
assumed also when it was going to be
made into a movie first you feel like
you're winning the lottery like the idea
that this is happening at all and you
have to constantly wake yourself up from
this like living dream you're having but
then you also assume it's going to be
CGI like the entire thing is going to be
this kind of pixel Fest you know so to
step on set and see the schools built to
full life and then see Sophie and Agatha
brought to life by these incredible
actresses it felt like an out of body
experience every step of the way because
it's so kind of transcendent and magical
and I think it reminds all of us the
power of our own creativity what can
possibly happen these these you know
experiences and thoughts inside of you
come to life it's been the greatest
honor of my life and I'm just very
excited that all the the readers and and
people who've lived in this world for
you know the last 10 years like I have
we'll get to see it on screen they did
your baby right oh yeah these two
especially I mean you can't get a better
Sofia and I get that then the two
Sophia's the two Sofias is squared
there are plenty of amazing magical
schools in literature and you know I
personally wish that I would have
enrolled in some of them what was your
inspiration to make this story stand
apart from the rest of those I just have
different energy I feel like I wanted a
magical school that felt like a Madonna
concert I wanted this kind of like high
female energy that was like powering the
school because it's always about a boy
it's time to move on from that and bring
forth a powerful you know female pair
when you think of fairy tales you think
princess and witch and what if they were
friends because to me a princess and a
witch in a way are the same they both
can't find happiness within themselves
they need something outside themselves a
princess needs love and a witch needs
the princess dead so that was really the
engine behind school for genevil that is
amazing I love that next question is
from Auntie smaller on Twitter for
Soleman what was it that Sophia and
Sophia brought to these roles that made
them the perfect choices for leads you
know what's so difficult about each
character is you know on the page I have
total freedom to create these these
contradictions within a character Sophie
is a Devon she's a Glam glamorous and
she's a narcissist but she's also
secretly compassionate and has a deep
heart and is a great friend at the end
of it but at the same time she's also
like you know hard as ice at times and
to find somebody who could play all
those aspects because Sophie in a lot of
ways is me we've discussed this a lot
someone and I are conjoined at the hip a
little bit yeah we are we are very
similar Sophie's unite you know where we
look at someone like Sophia Wiley slash
Agatha who is good to the Bone and we
don't quite understand them yeah we have
had this conversation
deep down I'm cool and evil wait can you
say that without a smile
I'm evil oh God you're smiling
I doubt what I got a little twinkle in
your eye I got that it was my conscience
you know Agatha is what I know I should
do I think Agatha has everybody's
conscience you know so Sophie was was
kind of you know behavior and Agatha was
a conscience and so the difference
between who you are and what you do I
think is at the center of the school of
evil and no one on earth can capture the
kind of glow and Humanity of Agatha like
Sophia Wiley I mean they looked all over
the world for Agatha because she's such
a big kind of iconic character in
children's literature now and
there was no one who could play her like
Sophia you know it's true at the same
time I remember being like at the
beginning Agatha has to be grumpy and
cynical and and have that kind of slight
evil energy at the beginning and we were
all like
but she pulls it off brilliantly you
guys did both did a fake out you really
did their pairing is um absolutely
fantastic and and the friendship is so
strong that it is really the pulsing
heart of oh yeah this movie I mean I
gotta say it is so powerful to see like
two badass ladies at the center of such
like an epic story like this it is a
dream this next question comes from
Melanie Sharpie Burgess on YouTube
what's your favorite scene in the book
that you shot I'm dying to know what
your favorite is you each had two
different scenes
um that I was sort of looking forward to
one was the Wish Fish scene I thought
because I don't know how you film that
but to do it outside with you know Kerry
Washington's Professor W and and the
Wish Fish and the story are these you
know fish um in the animal communication
class that can read your greatest wish
you put your finger in this kind of
magical Lake and they tell you what your
soul wants and Agatha's wish ultimately
is very revealing and so to see that
brought to life with you and Carrie
there was just that was sort of this
chills moment because that came that
really came from the heart to see it on
screen was a big deal and then Sophie
the two Moments One is kind of the
fashion parade
um and writing that in the book was one
of my favorite moments you know I think
at some point she shows up in a chain
mail bustier in the book and write it or
was at the time was like this cannot be
in a children's book and I'm like I'm
not touching it and so to see to see
that kind of energy in all of your
outfits I thought was something amazing
and you play it so well that was fun
it is so iconic I I think I agree my
favorite scene was the whole Wish Fish
and stimp scene there was a lot of
things that were not there that I had to
act with and so I think that was one of
the most challenging days of all because
I I just remember talking to my my mom
and my dad and I was like I'm not
looking at anything I'm having to like
talk to things that aren't there and
imagine and it was it really made me
have to channel my inner child and that
imagination that you have because there
were so many things that I just I I
completely had to create in my own head
that's why I'm always encouraging kids
to read and and because ultimately your
imagination is the greatest power you
have and you can only develop that by
reading in a lot of ways because it you
know when you read a book it's your
version right so everybody who's read
the school for example you know there's
millions of different versions out there
and every kid has their personal one and
when they come to see the movie finally
this is a version they can actually
share with their friends and family you
know but they're still going to have
their own you know each of you have your
own I have my own we all have our own
version of a story but a movie gives you
an opportunity to sort of collectively
come together
and and show it off here's the question
for you guys I think is so the reason I
wanted it to be about a female
friendship is I remember growing up and
in middle school and high school the way
that two girls would almost form this
kind of you know Union that was
unbreakable they would always be
together sleepovers you know they would
go to the bathroom together like they
were just always together like always
together and then you know a boy or a
third party would appear at some point
and create the slightest crack in the
foundation of the friendship and then
the question was whether the two girls
could get back together again the way
they were and I felt like that was a
story I'd seen over and over in real
life and so I was just curious you know
your own experiences in life and and
whether you've seen that sort of play
out absolutely I've had a lot of
girlfriends and it's difficult and
Sophia knows this growing up in an
industry like this and it's hard
actually to find like female friendships
that are really genuine and Lasting and
solid because it is this sort of like
there's a very competitive nature so for
me at least there's
there's been that and it's always been
difficult and I think that Sophie has
that competitive nature and I think that
Sophia Wiley I think that we have the
bond is the point I'm getting at and
then um I think we maybe can both relate
to having this struggle of like third
parties coming in or whether that's
frustration like jealousy or whether
that's a boy or whatever it would be
it's always been difficult for me to
have like lasting female friendships but
I think that at the end Sophia and I got
to have that and I think I think we as
as Pals have that too yeah I've seen
that a lot as well in my life like I
always tell myself friendships last much
longer than most relationships do that's
true so I will always try my best to put
my friends before any romantic feelings
I may have for somebody in a moment I
can always lean on your friends yes
always lean on your friends because they
they really are are there for you in
ways that most people aren't they know
your heart and they accept you for who
you are and that Union that you're
talking about between two girls it is
really something so special I think my
best friend is my sister and of course
that's a bond stronger than just like
friendship we are blood literally
everything I'm going through she has
gone through or is going through or is
going to go through like we know each
other inside and out and so that bond is
unbreakable no matter if I
scream at her one day or we punch each
other and we don't punch each other come
on but like when we fight there's
there's always that underlying love and
I think that represents Sophie and add
to this relationship so much they love
each other no matter if they're the bond
of a sister is like it never breaks
technically technically I mean come on
the resemblance is uncanny come on I'm
also thinking like it's so funny because
Sophia's like and I wouldn't always put
a friend first and meanwhile I'm
thinking as a true Sophie we're like
yeah
so Sophia and Sophia this last one is
for you we have one more Super Fan who
has a question for you actually and they
submitted a video so we're gonna take a
look at that right now hey ladies how's
it going
I miss you terribly I hear you're taking
fan questions though uh do you mind if I
ask you one great okay here's my
question do you want to see an exclusive
tease of the school for good and evil
I would like to without any further Ado
introduce to the world the school for
good and evil roll it
did you ever wonder
[Music]
where every Great Fairy Tale begins
where the good become Heroes
and the evil become villains
welcome
we've been expecting you
what was that
this is it this is real
[Music]
oh
that's so sick oh I hope my parents
gotta see that this is so exciting
because this is the first time that
anyone is seeing anything from that so
everyone's gonna freak out just like you
guys we officially know now that the
school for good and evil is coming this
September it's happening it's coming
we're so excited we can't wait how does
it feel to see that I love it we should
be proud of what we did that was hard
work that's insane it always is a little
terrifying because we do our best as
actors to put everything we can into a
role and then when we're done filming we
have to just trust so much trust but
Paul feig is incredible he is literally
not stopped working on this since we've
wrapped a year ago and I can see the
work has really shown itself it's so
incredible it's beautiful it's so much
like darker than I was imagining but I
love that I love the look of it the
cinematography it's just stunning and
it's so exciting yeah it's pretty cool
so man how do you feel when you see that
I just think that moment where the bird
takes them towards the school is
literally like it just felt like ripped
out of all of our imagination like when
she says it's real like that's a line
straight from the book so when I saw it
I just thought to myself who's not going
to want to see this movie The Whole
World's Gonna Fall in Love with these
two girls very shortly did it girl power
girl pass Solomon Sophia Sophia thank
you so much for being here it was a
pleasure to talk to you guys and have
this moment having geeked week and
having you guys and revealing everything
thank you and thank you for having us
I'm very very excited oh my God you guys
are the best I can't wait to just spend
a year running around the world with you
I'm ready
[Music]
and for those of you at home there's
plenty more in store for the school for
good and evil before it comes out on
Netflix this September so be sure to
follow Netflix geeked and Netflix film
for all of the updates I'll be back here
at geeked week this Friday for a live
episode of the geeked podcast where me
and my co-host princess weeks are gonna
break down all the best moments of
geeked week including this panel geek
week continues tomorrow with the whole
day dedicated to animation so
you there bye
foreign
[Music]